[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est l'heure de
politique à table sur lcp on va parler
cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologie avec moi pour présenter cette
émission jean-pierre montanay bonjour
jean pierre bonjour bullshit pour jour
nicolas giraud bonjour bonjour nicolas
giraud vous êtes porte-parole de la
confédération paysanne un syndicat qui
se bat pour une reconnaissance du droit
à la souveraineté alimentaire c'est
d'actualité contre les multinationales
vous êtes alter mondialiste attachés au
respect de l'environnement vous plaider
pour une meilleure répartition des
subventions agricoles et un meilleur
prix payés aux producteurs
vous avez d'ailleurs travaillé sur la
loi et galim sur laquelle vous portez un
regard pour le moins critique vous nous
en parlera et comme l'un de vos
prédécesseurs le célèbre josé bové vous
mener parfois des actions un peu musclé
comme en poitou charentes contre les
grandes retenues d'eau qui cacherait un
pompage des nappes phréatiques selon
vous ce qui vous a valu un petit détour
par le commissariat producteurs de vache
à lait dans le jura pour la fabrication
de comté et de morbier on va parler du
menu du jour avec lui jean pierre et
bien au menu de la viande et du boeuf
bourguignon et pour le sucre est un must
de la carte des cerfs des brasseries une
crème brûlée dans le dessus des plats
l'innovation au service des paysans
russes connectés insectes au secours de
l'alimentation animale ou bacon
végétales notre reporter a arpenté les
allemands et les allées du salon de
l'agriculture dans les pieds dans le
plat les conséquences de la guerre en
ukraine sur notre agriculture quels sont
les secteurs les plus impactés
qu'attendent les paysans du plan de
résilience promis par le chef de l'état
réponse à suivre
allez on passe à table a tout de suite
cuisine et confidente ici
[Musique]
alors nicolas giraud comme vous êtes
éleveurs dans le jura j'avais parié avec
brigitte que vous auriez envie de nous
faire découvrir une spécialité de votre
terroir notamment ses délicieux poisson
qui ont le mérite de ne pas vider les
océans puisqu'il prospère dans les
rivières et dans les lacs du massif du
jura comme la truite fario ou moins
connus le corps est jeune je ne sais pas
si vous connaissez un poisson qui est
proche du saumon mais non c'est votre
proximité sans doute avec les vaches et
votre combat pour défendre l'élevage qui
ont inspiré votre estomac on aura donc
droit à de la barbaque comme on est
comme on dit de la viande un gros mot
depuis que russel le communiste s'est
fait triper par la gauche pour avoir osé
défendre le steak français voilà donc un
plateau thème de la cuisine française de
boeuf bourguignon qui marie deux
attractions de cette région qui est
aussi un peu la vôtre le vin rouge et le
cheptel bovin un mariage devenues
clivant aujourd'hui alors que la
nourriture se politise vous assumez ce
boeuf au vin monsieur giraud bah oui oui
oui j'assume complètement ce boeuf
bourguignon ce boeuf au vin huile très
clairement alors c'est vrai que j'aurais
pu aller sur une truite au vin jaune
comme on le commande les cuisines chez
nous ou même une fondue une fondue
comtoise savoyard mal de fromages etc
mais c'est vrai que
[Musique]
l'intérêt du boeuf bourguignon c'est de
valoriser la viande de valoriser des
morceaux de viande qui sont des fois un
petit peu oublié
moi comme j'avais réfléchi à ça c'est
une cuisine qu'on fait dans les
campagnes mes parents mes grands parents
on a l'habitude de valoriser l'ensemble
des morceaux des animaux qu'on pouvait
élever à battre sur l'affairé c'est un
plat familial que vous aviez l'habitude
de manger un
plat qu'on avait l'habitude de manger
qui se réchauffe qui se garde donc on
peut pas manger que du rôti aux du steak
il faut aussi manger les morceaux qui
doivent être un peu plus clément sur une
table et moi j'ai fait ont leur place
dans la cuisine française moi je pense
oui moi je pense que oui et puis et puis
l'élevage a toute sa place
dans
l'alimentation et puis dans
l'agriculture française et mondiale donc
d'où l'intérêt quand on m'a demandé il
voit la choisissez un plat je me suis
dit il faut un plat pour moi avec de la
viande avec deux pour signifier
l'intérêt de l'élevage et ne pas laisser
à penser que ben
l'élevage est anti climatique l'élevage
j'entendais le discours quand même
ambiant qui dit qu'il faut manger moins
de viande à la fois pour la santé pour
l'environnement ça vous agace ou vous
reconnaissez que oui peut-être il faut
manger mieux du hand mais moins de
viande je pense qu'il faut surtout
manger mieux c'est une certitude
en mangez moi je pense qu'il ya des
catégories de des catégories qui peuvent
en manger moi je pense que tout le monde
n'a pas forcément accès à de la viande
régulièrement donc globalisé c'est
peut-être un petit peu un petit peu
simpliste mais en tout cas à manger
mieux ça c'est une certitude c'est à
dire que d'avoir eu donc ton connaît la
provenance française vous êtes un peu
chauvin là dessus aussi c'est pas
forcément attaché ce que j'ai on est
capable en france de faire de la
malbouffe aussi faut être faut être
honnête quand on remplace des poulets
qu'on veut importer du brésil par du
poulet industriel français je vois
combien la différence moi j'ai pas
témoigne manger français dans ce cas là
j'ai plutôt envie de manger
une viande paysanne quoi une viande qui
est lié au sol qui se nourrit de son
territoire alors elle serait aussi le
bien-être animal de la bonne
alimentation pour pour l'élevage mais
bien entendu ça va tout tout ça doit
rentrer en ligne de compte 160 j'imagine
dans le goût de la viande vous allez
goûter ce plat bien sûr vous allez me
dire ce que ce que vous en pensez
si vous rappelle le boeuf de votre
enfance et pendant ce temps là
jean-pierre peut-être trois choses à
savoir surtout comment réussir son banc
bourguignon alors non seulement pour le
réussir mais pour le bien le réussir et
alors je vais d'abord revenir sur ce que
disait nicolas giraud s'est il faut
d'abord bien choisir la viande de boeuf
alors vous pouvez demander conseil à
votre boucher vous avez un bon boucher
je crois brigitte et il sait vous dire
quels sont les morceaux alors il faut
opter pour des morceaux à braiser comme
le paleron ou la macreuse de boeuf et là
je viens dans le sens de nicolas giraud
parce que ça ce sont des produits qui
sont moins nobles qui sont à braiser à
faire cuire longtemps et qui sont
souvent pas cher un boeuf bourguignon ce
n'est pas un plat de viande très cher
par rapport à une entrecôte ou une côte
de boeuf on peut aussi rajouter moi
j'aime bien des morceaux plus gélatineux
pour donner un peu de consistance à la
source ce qui est intéressant dans le
boeuf bourguignon ce qu'on peut avoir un
panel de différentes viandes ensuite
avant de le faire braiser je vous donne
un conseil c'est
prenez soin de saisir d'abord les
morceaux de viande avec un peu de
graisse avant on les saisies c'est avec
du saindoux mais on peut aussi les
saisir avec un peu d'huile ça va dégager
des sucs et donner un peu plus du de
goût à la sauce et surtout ça va tenir
les petits morceaux de boeuf ensuite et
puis bien sélectionner enfin le vin je
vous fais confiance à brigitte pas
question de recycler la piquette que je
vous aime lorsque ma vie un accueil
privilégié un bourgogne bien sûr pour
faire le boeuf bourguignon sans pour
autant dilapidés dans ce plat un peu
marre grands crus mais un conseil
j'espère que nicolas giraud est d'accord
avec moi il faut plutôt prendre à vin un
peu corsé et puissant pour soutenir la
viande bah oui moi je pense aussi je
suis pas je suis pas hyper spécialisés
consignes mais mais en tout cas oui tout
ce que vous dites là sur le les morceaux
à choisir et puis le levain à mettre
avec elle vous plait sa place en mai oui
oui moi ça me plaît ça me plait
complètement c'est vraiment pas les
souvenirs de boeuf bourguignon qu'on
pouvait avoir à la maison en famille un
plat qu'on partage à dire que l'on n'est
pas on n'est pas à deux à manger un
boeuf bourguignon c'est là où tout le
monde est tombé autour de la table et
vous savez le cuisiner vous aimez vous
passer un peu de temps en cuisine on
vous avait pas trop le temps non ça ne
fait pas que j'ai pas trop le temps on
peut je pourrais trouver le temps je
suis pas quelqu'un qui cuisine beaucoup
je vais pas commencer à dire ça ce que
ma femme
me reprocherait de dire ça il me mettre
en avant là dessus très bas même giroud
qui était au fond on aurait plutôt ma
c'est plutôt ma femme qui prépare notre
femme quand il ya un grand repas des
amis ou la famille à table on aime bien
on aime bien tout ce qui est à base
de produits de chez nous ça peut être ça
peut être
des produits issus de l'élevage ça peut
être tout ce qui est on n'a pas de
poulets chez nous mais la volaille de
ferme avec
avec tous les produits issus du vignoble
jurassien aussi avec dû compter avec
nous aujourd'hui
réparation n'a toujours sur sur la table
le plateau de fromages de toute façon
avec avec le conte et le morbier le
laisse que ce fromage vous mettez dans
des recettes aussi vous faites gratiner
en permanence des choses avec votre
compte et où c'est le comté brut avec un
bon morceau de parchemin surtout le
comté moi j'adore mettre des morceaux de
compte et forcément quand on fait quand
on fait des repas rapides avec des
patous quand on se fait même des oeufs
au plat touche un mot là dessus dans la
soupe dans la soupe à votre compte et
enfin le contester ce sont qu'on le voit
partout alors on va voir si vous êtes
incollables c'est le quiz
alors nicolas giraud votre lait permet
de confectionner on vient de le dire du
morbier du comté a qui sont des bonnes
pâtes du jura mais seriez vous
reconnaître ce fromage culte qui se
cache derrière ces affirmations ah il
est produit en ardèche dans la drôme le
gard et le vaucluse b il s'agit d'une
pâte molle à croûte naturelle c il exige
au minimum 14 jours d'affinage et des
questions saveur il exhale des arômes
caprins et des notes de noisette qui
suis-je
et fromages culte pour mettre un peu sur
la piste c'est pas un fromage inconnu
que j'étais un fromage agonisant c'est
le picodon oui
[Musique]
alors ques numéro 2 vous êtes éleveur de
vaches laitières alors on va voir si
vous êtes incollable sur la race des
vaches qu'elle est l'intrus dans cet
inventaire à la bazadaise b la
ferrandaise c'est la charmoise des la
mirandaise
il ya un sweat l'air compliqué je dirais
la charmoise mais je suis pas
effectivement fouquet d'accord pareil je
me dis comme race de vache je
connaissais pas parce que si vous
trouvez
vous créditez bon et vous vous avez des
vaches laitières vous avez quoi comme
jeu laitière on a des montbéliardes des
mondes il ya des montbéliardes bien on a
36 vaches laitières à peu près sur la
ferme contre est contré toute l'année on
est donc deux sur la ferme mon frère et
moi et puis les relations familiales de
génération en génération moi c'est mon
grand-père qu'avec est revenu sur sur le
site dans le jura qui s'est installée
mon père s'est installée fin des années
60 est mon frère et moi on s'est
installé lui dans les années 90 et moi
tout début des années 2000 donc ferme
qui évolue gentiment avec le temps mais
qui reste voici c'est maintenant on veut
rester sur une petite ferme on a la
chance avec le conte est d'avoir une
bonne valorisation du lait donc on peut
se permettre ce choix là de ne pas être
dans dans l'engrenage du toujours plus
est-ce que vous ne vendez pas de lait
directement vous transformer tous nos
transforme pas la ferme on transforme à
la fruitière donc à la coopérative mais
depuis tout petit on a toujours expliqué
nous on n'est pas vendeur de lait on est
vendeur de compte et c'est à dire que on
met notre lait en commun dans la
fromagerie à la coopérative il est
fabriqué tous les jours en comté et en
morbier et ensuite la coopérative qui
est nous qui sont à l'ensemble des des
paysannes et paysans du sud de la
coopérative on vend ce fromage anneaux
affineur qui ensuite la finale
commercialise mais vous ne produisez pas
sur mac c'est intéressant on en parlait
juste avant que l'antenne commence ou ne
produisait pas ce fromage dans votre
ferme dans quoi non pas parce que l'on
pourrait produire le morbier à la ferme
le vert bien a le droit d'avoir un comté
morbier fermiers le comté peut pas être
produits à la ferme parce que le compte
était obligatoirement un led mélange
bien qu'il faut mélanger le lait de
plusieurs fermes pour faire un compte et
c'est ce qu'avait été pensé par
l'inventeur nos anciens qui avaient
pensé le comté comme un fromage de garde
mais un gros fromage fromage qui fait 40
kg qui nécessite entre 400 et 450 litres
de lait donc
niveau pour produire ce lait dans des
toutes petites firmes ya très longtemps
c'était compliqué donc il y avait
obligatoirement du lait qui était mis en
commun et ils ont eu l'intelligence de
garder ça et de dire ben on va garder
terrey de se mettre ensemble pour faire
un compte et ce qui nous oblige sur
notre territoire nous entendre avec nos
voisins gentils le goût peut-être de
mélanger les laits je pense que oui oui
je pense que ce diversité sont ça va
amener plus de diversité mais après tout
en ayant un territoire qui attachent à
chaque coopérative parce que chaque
petite coopérative dans le jura et dans
le doubs palmas sur le massif du jura
est encore entre aux environs de 130 140
coopérative qui fabrique du comté eh ben
c'est des petites des petites
coopératives que parce qu'on n'a pas le
droit d'aller ramasser le lait à comté à
plus de 25 kilomètres autour de la
coopérative donc on est obligé d'en
avoir un certain nombre et le paysan
perso qui veut faire son compte et tout
seul dans son coin il pourra jamais
l'appeler contessi n'utilise que son
lait c'est ça il pourra jamais l'appeler
comptait donc le comté est allée est un
fromage collectif on verrait alors vous
dans la confédération paysanne vous
défendez un prix décent pour
l'agriculteur pour l'éleveur est ce que
le fait justement de transformer votre
lait ça apporte un revenu qui est plus
important c'est plus intéressant
financièrement oui lui c'est plus
intéressant parce que la valeur ajoutée
qui est due aussi à la transformation en
fromage permet de générer du revenu et
si on arrive à cette valeur ajoutée à
cela va répartir comme nous rend compte
et intelligemment entre les différents
entre les différentes familles j'allais
dire du comté entre les producteurs
les affineurs et bien voilà ça permet
une meilleure rémunération après se dire
que on ne pourrait avoir une bonne
rémunération des agriculteurs que si on
transforme et on va au bout des choses
c'est pas ce n'est pas entendable c'est
pas acceptable c'est à dire que
quelqu'un qui produit
une matière noble
la viande etc transforme pas le produit
s'il se transforme pas même s'il n'a pas
la main sur la transformation il devrait
y avoir derrière une rémunération qu'ils
soient justement là on vient de finir un
peu les négociations entre justement les
producteurs les éleveurs et la grande
distribution les intermédiaires il ya eu
cette loi et galim 2 vous avez participé
aussi à l'élaboration de cette première
loi est ce que finalement vous avez
l'impression se fait pas quelle était la
tendance au salon de l'agriculture mais
que les éleveurs et les agriculteurs
s'en sortait mieux cette année
je suis pas sûr que qui s'en sortent
beaucoup mieux notamment dans les
filières qui était mise en difficulté
déjà avant avancer c'est l'oreille galim
1 et 2 notamment les filières d'élevage
viande et lait c'était beaucoup pour
celle là que ça ait dépensé
le fait de dalé un petit peu plus loin
dans la loi et galim 2 que dans la une
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant mais
qui nous sommes nous pas allé
suffisamment loin encore c'est à dire
qu'on est encore dans un contexte qui
fait que l rapport de force dans la
négociation est défavorable toujours au
monde agricole par rapport à ses
acheteurs transformateurs pas garanti a
pris mon revenu garanti c'est à dire que
ce qui est garanti dans la loi et galim
deux sessions actualisation du prix
comme il ya une sanctuarisation de la
partie agricole dans la négociation
entre entre transformateurs et
distributeurs
c'est à dire qu'on sent que tu as he is
dans ma négociations entre contributeurs
ce qui n'existait pas mais 7 7 mais pas
le niveau de la partie agricole qui est
sanctuarisé rien n'est dit qu'elle doit
être supérieur au coût de revient du
père heures on peut très bien avoir une
sanctuarisation de cette partie dans la
négo vous et défendra transformateurs et
distributeurs qu'il soit en dessous de
nos coûts de production elle veut dire
que la loi et galim de l est pas
suffisante il faudra aller encore plus
loin nous pour nous il faudra encore
aller il faudra encore aller plus loin
c'est à dire que il faut avoir des
garde-fous qui permettent de dire que à
partir d'un moment d'un seuil on ne
négocie plus le monde agricole ne doit
pas pouvoir continuer à être
à ce qu'on lui achète ses produits en
dessous de ses coûts de revient ou en
dessous de 80 % de ses coûts de revient
fayyad il ya des choses à triturer et à
travailler mais aujourd'hui on a des
indicateurs de coûts de production qui
doivent permettre de définir
quel niveau qui devrait permettre de
rémunérer les paysans mais après c'est
le fruit de la négociation c'est à dire
que si nos acheteurs arrivent en disant
ah oui il ya ces indicateurs de coûts de
production mais nous sommes assez
d'indicateurs là nous de nos marchés on
va faire un mixte tout ça elle pour
l'atterrissage il peut être en dessous
des coûts de production des paysans et
vous êtes en des eaux non on n'est pas
en agriculture biologique quoi
pourquoi parce que on est beaucoup plus
attachés encore une fois à notre terroir
notre territoire et la production de
lait à comté à dire qu'on est plus
attaché à notre coopérative fruitière où
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'autres
producteurs qui sont allés à compter dix
ans qui sont en agriculture biologique
on essaie d'en amener avec nous qu'ils
passent en agriculture biologique on
pourrait passer en bio et mais faudrait
changer de fruitière et on n'a pas envie
c'est la fruitière du village vous à la
confédération paysanne vous défendez
aussi beaucoup l'environnement ouais ça
ne va pas de pair en allant presser
c'est quand même une tendance forte et
il n'y a pas que l'agriculture
biologique qui défend l'environnement
c'est-à-dire que l'on peut avoir nous on
est dedans on est plutôt dans une
dynamique d'agriculture paysanne en se
disant que on a sept cette ambition de
qualité des produits de liens
l'environnement et j'ai pas forcément
besoin d'être en agriculture biologique
pour ne pas utiliser de pesticides ou
utiliser très peu d'engrais azotés et et
avoir une une envie d'avoir cette
durabilité de mes pratiques ce serait un
plus d'aller en agriculture biologique
très clairement mais voilà encore une
fois moi j'ai j'ai envie d'aller en
agriculture biologique collectivement
avec les producteurs de la comté qui
sont sur la même sur le même territoire
que ne voudriez pas plus cher votre
compte et bio et ça vous permettrai pas
d'être encore plus valorisées de
valoriser davantage votre lait on le
vendra plus cher ça c'est une certitude
après faut se rend compte qu'on aurait
aussi nous on est sur un territoire où
on produit pas de céréales parce qu'on
est sur un territoire montagneux
il se fait des céréales dans le jura
mais pas sur notre secteur on est dans
un territoire accidenté donc on achète
toutes les céréales pour l'hiver pour
les animaux le tourteau de soja de colza
en parlais tout à l'heure avec une crise
par exemple et si on devait passer en
agriculture biologique on devrait
acheter ces produits là en bio donc pour
nécessairement mieux rémunérer les
céréaliers bio l'achèterai pas plus cher
et donc donc le différentiel entre
finalement le point d'équilibré qu'on a
aujourd'hui en compte et
conventionnelles et celui qu'on aurait
en compte et bio serait pas
fondamentalement différent en terme de
rémunération alors en france vous savez
que le repas occupe une assez large
place essais souvent autour d'un bon
plat que se trouvent les meilleures
histoires c'est la brève de comptoir
alors nicolas giraud vous a demandé de
réfléchir à un souvenir autour d'un
repas qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter
donc j'en avais en tête 2 je vais en
géant choisir un des deux c'était au
salon de l'agriculture il ya il ya trois
quatre ans hu a peut-être même plus où
ou cinq ans était un des premiers salons
de la culture où je venais en tant que
secrétaire national de la confédération
paysanne j'étais pas encore porte parole
à ce moment là et on a une fois par
semaine au salon de l'agriculture un
déjeuner avec le ministre à interbev qui
l interprofession des bétails du bétail
et viande est un petit déjeuner où
l'ensemble des familles de
l'interprofession sont là les
producteurs les transformateurs les
distributeurs
les coopérateurs et le ministre qui est
là pour répondre aux interpellations des
uns et des autres et donc on arrive pour
ce petit déj entre 7h et 7h30 et on
rentre sur le stand d'interbev et moi
c'était la première fois que j'allais en
arrive là la tablette installés et sont
dans les assiettes
il est 7h30 du matin du ris de veau une
bouteille de rouge en face en face de
chacun
on attaque on attaque avec le rideau est
ensuite passez à côté de nous les
serveurs pendant que chacun parle dans
le ministre parle ou les autres parlent
et nous demandent ce qu'on veut en place
que là c'était que l'entrée donc en
place et côtes d'agneau pavé de boeuf ou
tête de veau donc voila quand on va pour
la première fois un petit déjeuner
d'interbev et qu'on se rend compte qu'on
se prépare ça ça
7h30 du matin c'est un petit peu tôt
pour la tête de veau quoi mais pas
l'appétit de jacques chirac vous non
j'ai pas la petite jacques chirac après
s'est bien passé je vous avoue que
j'avais dû prendre le pavé de boeuf bon
j'ai pas eu faim avant deux heures de
l'après midi donc on avait pu faire une
bonne journée de salon bien intense il
s'est passé quelque chose que vous avez
obtenu des concessions à la part du
ministre à 7,7 nabeul on n'obtient pas
forcément des concessions à ce moment là
au salon de l'agriculture on a on avait
surtout si on était déjà dans les
discussions autour des négociations
commerciales autour des lois et galim
c'était avec didier guillaume à cette
époque là et on avait comme on a
toujours quand même un ministre qui dans
ces moments là est capable de taper du
poing sur la table par rapport aux
distributeurs aux transformateurs qui
joue pas forcément toujours le jeu de
l'année gomis y allait de la répartition
de la valeur à ça suffit pas un ministre
qui tape du poing sur la table lors d'un
petit déjeuner bon c'est toujours c'est
toujours mieux que ça et dans l'autre
sens alors aujourd'hui les agriculteurs
vous le savez sont des entrepreneurs
créatifs aidés par les nouvelles
technologies il innove c'est le dessous
des plats
[Musique]
et oui brigitta le salon de
l'agriculture n'est pas que le
rendez-vous des éleveurs de vaches à
l'ancienne et de gallinacés c'est aussi
l'agriculture de demain qui se dessine
avec des innovations dans
l'agroalimentaire et des nouvelles
technologies qui s'invite au service des
agriculteurs
c'est un reportage de nicolas coadout et
soraya la uci
entre les lapins et les vaches
bazadaises au salon de l'agriculture un
stand des tonnes et affiche un objectif
bien ambitieux attendu autour de la même
table des vols des viandards enrobé
gagnent grâce à un produit roux
incroyable s'est produit ce sont des
lardons et du bacon à base d'huile de
tournesol et de protéines de soja une
recette 100% végétale et des produits
qui reproduisent à la cuisine est ce
qu'on adore dans la viande donc ce gras
qui crée vide et qu'ils influent dans la
bâtiment du produit et on a réussi à
reproduire ça et donc du coup on arrive
au qui met tout le monde d'accord à la
dégustation même le boucher a failli
c'est
[Musique]
un peu plus loin dans les allées la
technologie est mise à l'honneur cette
entreprise propose des ruches connecter
pour les agriculteurs
mesure en continu un automatique
l'activité et la santé des abeilles de
façon à déterminer des indicateurs de
qualité environnementale pour aider les
agriculteurs la transition écologique la
santé des abeilles et mesurer en continu
notamment l'analyse de leur mortalité
qui donnerait une excellente indication
sur l'état de l'environnement à
l'agriculteur et l'agriculteur en
lui-même et des gens capacité d'avoir de
proposer des solutions puisque
finalement c'est son métier c'est un
agronome d'agriculteurs c'est le vrai
gestionnaire du foncier et donc c'est
lui qui va pouvoir mettre en place des
tout simplement une stratégie de
corrections et d'améliorations continues
certains se projette encore plus loin si
2050 on va devoir nourrir 10 milliards
de personnes avec que 3 % de terres
disponibles comment est ce qu'on fait
inpex est une entreprise de 250 salariés
qui est legs et transforme des insectes
pour en faire des ingrédients pour la
nutrition des animaux des plantes et des
êtres humains à l'origine il faut
imaginer d'immenses ferme à insectes
plusieurs centaines de tonnes de
scarabées notamment
une matière première abondante
transformé en protéines alimentaires ou
en huile végétale ici rien ne se perd
même les déjections cerveau à produire
de l'engrais agricole
annulé et on va après le vendre à des
pros à des à des gens qui vont le vendre
soit à des agriculteurs pour des
céréales pour des maraîchers etc ou soit
à des particuliers insect exporte ses
produits dans déjà plus de 20 pays alors
on a trois exemples d'innovations
laquelle de ces trois vous bluff le plus
est à vos yeux incarne ce qui représente
l'agriculture de demain
je suis pas sûr que l'agriculture de
demain soit seulement trait à
l'innovation pas moi déjà annoncé sur
notre question ouest sur ces trois
innovations si on les regarde puisque
c'est assez spectaculaire du bacon
végétales des abeilles qui sont
suivis au doigt et à l'oeil et puis ces
insectes qui vont peut-être remplacer
votre boeuf bourguignon qu'est-ce-qui de
ces trois pour vous dans votre esprit
incarne cette agriculture qui se dessine
un peu du mal à répondre à 44 3 j'allais
dire la moins pire la moins pire
ce serait les insectes
aussi pour réfléchir à l'alimentation
animale
j'avoue que l'alimentation humaine on a
sûrement du chemin à faire on n'est
peut-être pas encore prêt mais
o la moins pire vous êtes dur parce que
c'est intéressant de savoir de pouvoir
suivre les comportements des abeilles et
d'en tirer des conséquences sur la
qualité de l'environnement ouais son
rapport à l'agriculture vous êtes dur je
trouve la saignée un petit peu que les
paysans et en l'occurrence les
apiculteurs ils savent déjà faire ça
donc c'est nier les savoir-faire ce
n'est rien pas besoin d'outils
technologiques comme un son est
peut-être précis pour amener un peu les
données on peut avoir besoin d'outils
technologiques après moi ce qui me
dérange dans ce qu'on appelle ça c'est
des outils dallas des aides à la
décision c'est que est-ce que c'est des
outils d'aidé à la décision ou à ce que
des essais des outils qui vont rendre
les paysans encore un peu plus dépendant
de certaines firmes qui vont à leur
vendre ça et puis qui vont les qui vont
remplacez l'intelligence et les cerveaux
paysans ce que pour nous enfin pour moi
le bon sens j'en sais rien mais la
transition agro écologiques elle va
faire part par l'inventivité des
cerveaux paysans alors je dis pas que ce
n'est pas l'intelligence artificielle
brigitte a raison les nouvelles
technologies les innovations ça va quand
même vous aider je pense je pense que ça
peut nous aider je pense que ça peu des
deux mais il faut pas que ça vienne
remplacer les paysans faut pas que ça
devienne les rendre encore un peu plus
dépendants et encore moins autonome et
prendre la place de faim moi moi je me
suis installé paysans pour être en lien
avec le vivant animal végétal je pense
que la plupart c'est ça on va pas
s'installer paysans pour conduire un
drone conduire un robot ou piloter sa
station météo et puis piloté son
tracteur à partir et à partir de ces
données là ça peut nous permettre
d'avoir des éléments de deux
d'ajustement mais elle avait rien que ça
dans votre ferme des drones des tout ça
non donc les pas les insectes vous dites
c'est quand même intéressant la personne
n'a dit ça peut nourrir peut-être 10
milliards d'êtres humains demain est ce
que ce sont les insectes on pourra
produire suffisamment je suis maintenant
médias il faut produire plus aujourd'hui
parce qu'il faut plus de souveraineté
alimentaire est-ce qu'on en est capable
est-ce qu'on peut le faire ou est-ce
qu'il faudra passer par l'étape insectes
alors je sais pas s'il faudra passer par
l'étape insectes je pense que ça peut
être une étape qui peut qui peut
permettre de travailler à cette
recherche d'autonomie et de souveraineté
alimentaire est en tout cas enfin on est
totalement opposé à ce que dit julien
normandie depuis quelques quelques jours
de plus en plus fort que la souveraineté
alimentaire passera par le produire plus
on
produit déjà super nourrir toute la
population était alimentaire elle
passera davantage par le produire mieux
et puis produire plus durablement ce
qu'aujourd'hui on se rend compte si on
prend l'exemple du bléquin plein dans
l'actualité avec la guerre en frêne et
ben les rendements en blé en france
depuis quelques années ils plafonnent
c'est à dire qu'on se rend compte que
malgré des ajustements techniques malgré
la volonté de produire plus et pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi parce que à force de
tirer sur les sols qui est quelque chose
de vivant on peut pas en tirer plus que
ce qu'ils ne peuvent donner c'est à dire
qu'on est peut-être arrivé à un niveau
où non seulement ça va ça va se
stabiliser mais au bout d'un moment ça
va décroître mais on n'est pas une belle
analyse et qu'aujourd'hui intensive on
n'est pas autosuffisants jambes mais on
peut on peut rechercher cette
autosuffisance et cette souveraineté
alimentaire en ayant à
un objectif de varier l'alimentation de
varier la production de répondre
d'entendre la demande alimentaire plutôt
que d'être juste sur une gestion de
l'offre et des volumes parce
qu'aujourd'hui on produit trop en fait
on produit trop il ya c'est un rapport
au creux des malades ya quelques années
qui pointait le fait qu'à 25% au niveau
mondial d'alimentation qui gaspillent
entre la production la transformation et
la distribution et la consommation 1 25%
c'est pas c'est pas rien vidéo anti
gaspillage mais bon pour vous c'est pas
on n'en est pas encore au point et qu'il
est maintenant on n'est pas encore tous
les cas y ait un vrai débat il ya deux
écoles un souci cette souveraineté
alimentaire qu'on doit gagner ou assuré
c'est effectivement vous retravailler
revenir à une agriculture plus
écologiques etc et puis ce on avait reçu
un jour la présidente du fn et ça c'est
produire plus parce qu'il ya plus de
bouches à nourrir parce qu'il faut aussi
assurer la souveraineté alimentaire de
pays amis de pays du maghreb qui peut
pas produire c'est aussi une question de
générosité ça remet en cause le
greenville agricole aussi alors on peut
de fait on on produira pas tous ici
d'autres pays de produits ne produiront
pas tout chez eux donc on a besoin
d'avoir ces échanges cette solidarité
etc mais se dire qu'on va produire la
souveraineté alimentaire pour d'autres
pays c'est déjà ne pas comprendre le
concept de souveraineté alimentaire la
souveraineté alimentaire tel que l'a
travaillée déposé avec ça a été déposée
à l'onu par la via campesina le réseau à
laquelle auquel adhère la confédération
paysanne au niveau mondial c'est le
droit des peuples des états à mettre en
place leur politique agricole et
alimentaire et à empêcher le dumping
vis-à-vis des des pays tiers donc c'est
le fait de pouvoir construire sur un
territoire nos politiques agricoles
alimentaires se veut pas dire que tout
le monde sera autosuffisant mais ça veut
dire que on va pas aller à mener la
souveraineté alimentaire comme la bonne
parole projet ce qui ne saurait pas
l'acquérir plus on amène sa faim moi je
prends un exemple souvent de des états
de l'ouest africain chez qui on déverse
nos surplus de lait on le ramène notre
lait en poudre ont
régressé en plus à l'huile de palme
parce que nous les protéines du lait on
s'en sert pour faire autre chose et il
ya une valorisation donc on enlève les
protéines du lait on remet de l'huile de
palme dessus on leur importe ça ça
arrive à un prix défiant toute
concurrence là-bas sur place ça crée des
désordres alimentaires chez les gens qui
le consomment ce que c'est pas de la
protéine
laitière normal j'allais dire et en plus
ça empêche toute toute possibilité de
bâtir la souveraineté alimentaire sur
ces territoires là donc ça et ça en plus
à grands coups de subventions parce que
la politique la culture française et
européenne est subventionnée bien
davantage que les politiques agricoles
africaines par exemple dans l'exemple
que nous avons vu il y avait aussi le
bacon végétales aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup d'habitudes alimentaires qui
sont en jeu végétarien flexitariens
vegan sans gluten et autres est ce que
le les paysans les agriculteurs doivent
également s'adapter à cette nouvelle
donne
je pense que il va falloir de fête
s'adapter à l'évolution des régimes
alimentaires et des choix alimentaires
de l'ensemble de la population après ce
qui est gênant dans leur portage qu'on a
vu c'est déjà l'utilisation des termes
qui ont une connotation
protéines animales comme picard
saucisses nuggets
qui sont détournés quelque part pour
faire croire qu'on mange de la viande
est en fait qu on mange pas de viande
moi ça me dérange pas que des gens ne
mangent pas de viande mais soit ils
l'assument et soit on se dit les choses
est ce que c'est vrai que là on veut
retrouver la forme on a l'impression que
les gens sont mal à l'aise avec le fait
de manger un produit qui est issu de
protéines végétales dire y'a pas être
mal à l'aise avec ça mais ne venons pas
opposer une alimentation à base de
protéines végétales alimentation à base
de protéines animales et là dans le
débat c'est ça qui est en train d'être
posées non n'a pas interdit le boostec
végétales non mais bacon on en parlait
encore ce matin normalement c'est
interdit mais le décret n'est pas n'a
pas toujours n'a toujours pas été
déposée nous on avait attaqué la société
de xavier niel qui s'appelait les
nouveaux fermiers qui s'appelle
maintenant apivore qui commercialise des
nuggets des saucisses et je ne sais plus
quoi végétaux on les avait attaqués pour
utilisation abusive de termes qui
qualifient de la viande mener l'enquêté
on a été déboutée parce que les décrets
n'ont pas été causés encore alors on
invite évoqué un peu les conséquences de
la guerre en ukraine on va y revenir
parce que vous savez cette guerre elle
est venue bousculer le quotidien des
agriculteurs et des éleveurs alors on en
parle et on met les pieds dans le plat
[Musique]
le blé qui s'envole à 400 euros la tonne
conséquences du conflit entre la russie
et l'ukraine qui exporte 30 % de cette
céréale consommée dans le monde l'orge
ou le maïs flambe aussi tout comme le
tourteau de tournesol qui sert à nourrir
nos bêtes sans compter la flambée des
prix de l'énergie nos agriculteurs nos
éleveurs sont fortement impactées comme
a pu le constater maria becker les
premiers impactés ce sont eux les
éleveurs dans son exploitation éric dion
élèves 190 il a vu s'envoler le prix de
leur alimentation s'est détruit qui
mangent du blé de l'orge un petit peu de
maïs bien complémentaires à sauter
et ça coûte de plus en plus cher en une
semaine le prix de la tonne de maïs à
prix 100 euros on vit au jour le jour
c'est à espérer que le prix du porc
suivent le prix des céréales est
autrement il va y avoir un revenu une
catastrophe au niveau de la filière
porcine pour l'instant je vais essayer
de résister en espérant je puisse
continuer à faire ce que j'aime quoi car
l'ukraine est le quatrième exportateur
mondial de maïs depuis le début du
conflit 19 millions de tonnes sont
bloqués les échanges sont à l'arrêt dans
les ports de la mer noire beaucoup de
bateaux sont bloqués ne peuvent pas
aller dans les ports qui sont par
ailleurs pour certains bombardé chargé
le maïs et repartir en mer noire pour
aller en mer méditerranée est ensuite
allé vers les destinations soit
européenne soit sud méditerranéenne ou
plus loin en asie alors les éleveurs
français vont devoir trouver d'autres
sources d'approvisionnement des élevages
les fabricants d'aliments du bétail ont
quand même généralement quelques
semaines de stocks mais on parle juste
de quelques semaines et après ce sera de
chercher des sources alternatives
notamment d'aller chercher du maïs
américain autre conséquence du conflit
le prix du gaz a bondi plus 60% lundi
matin or ce gaz les coopératives en ont
besoin pour faire sécher les céréales et
maintenir leur qualité et c'est moins
connu le gaz sert à fabriquer de
l'engrais est nécessaire aux récoltes
alors les agriculteurs redoutent une
augmentation des prix des engrais voir
une pénurie pour l'année prochaine on
est encore plus inquiet
beaucoup d'expos de la chance à froid
comme aux causes aux jeunes les deux
boucles héros car l'europe importe 30%
de son engrais de russie la guerre en
ukraine aura certainement des
répercussions sur les récoltes c'est
toute la filière qui s'attend à des
perturbations
nicolas giraud est ce que vous vous êtes
impactés par cette guerre entre la
russie et l'ukraine est ce qu'il ya un
effet sur vos sur vos bêtes sur
l'alimentation vos bêtes et est-ce que
vous avez chiffré ce manque à gagner
pour l'instant on n'a pas d'impact
direct il va il va arriver
mais nous sur la ferme par exemple on a
une contractualisation sur un an sur nos
achats de tourteaux et céréales donc
en a encore jaillir un petit peu le
temps de devoir venir mais ça il va y
avoir un impact économique ça c'est une
certitude là où il ya un impact plus
rapide c'est notamment dans les élevages
qui sont hors sol c'est à dire que ou
l'alimentation est majoritairement ou
exclusivement basée sur des achats
d'alimentation extérieurs à la ferme
extérieurs au territoire nous on a la
chance avec nos vaches qui sont des
ruminants elles mangent de l'herbe l'été
du foin l'hiver produit sur la ferme
récoltés sur la ferme quand on a un
élevage de volailles ou de porc comme on
l'a vu dans le reportage on se retrouve
plus rapidement impacté par par ces
questions là est ce que la solution
c'est de faire peut-être des réserves
des stocks de d'alimentation animale
d'organiser ça ça existe peut-être déjà
ça existe déjà en partie il ya des
stocks européens qui existe sur lesquels
il va falloir s'appuyer pour pour
répondre à ça il y en a suffisamment
aureilhan n'ayant pas suffisamment tout
dépend de combien de temps ça va durer
après voilà on n'aime personne n'a
aucune lecture de ce qui va se passer ce
qui va y avoir un peu de production en
russie en ukraine ce qui va y en avoir 2
0 qu'est ce qui va se passer là bas et
ailleurs en europe voilà donc les les
impacts sont compliqués à à voir venir
et moi juste 20 c'est ce que j'ai dit
régulièrement tout au long du salon
c'est bien qu'on se préoccupe de sa ne
pas moins en tant que citoyen mêmes
paysans je voudrais qu'on se préoccupe
déjà des gens qui sont sous les bombes
sur place se dire des impacts
économiques on les gérera après ils vont
arriver il faut y réfléchir déjà
prenons-les toutes les dispositions
nécessaires mais vous vous réclamez je
l' ai vu un cessez le feu c'est votre
première préoccupation plutôt que de
s'apitoyer sur votre propre sort c'est
assez sa tronche avec d'autres
organisations syndicales qui ont tout de
suite vu le malheur des paysans c'est un
peu votre côté humanitaire où ça a été
sa liste peut-être mais ça a été hyper
violent quelques jours avant le salon on
a sorti un communiqué de presse avec eux
via campesina en europe parce qu'il ya
des organisations paysannes qui sont
tout proches y'a pas d'organisations
paysannes en ukraine en tout cas pas
dans notre organisation mais on en
roumanie en pologne et qui voyaient déjà
ça de tout près comment est-ce qu'on
gère
l'afflux des réfugiés comment est-ce
qu'on est solidaire avec les civils et
les populations locales impactés donc on
a fait un communiqué de presse très vite
surtout que n'arrivait en effet à nos
oreilles que c'est ses craintes par
rapport à un impact économique nous de
notre vision de français d'occidentaux
etc c'est hyper violent à recevoir donc
on n'a pas pu faire autrement et pendant
le salon la répéter régulièrement que
les premiers impacts et les premiers qui
vont trinquer c'est ce que disent et
christiane lambert à un moment donné je
l'avais dit dans l'oreillette de public
sénat la présidente de la fnc elle
disait que c'est l'agroalimentaire qui
va trinquer comme il a trinqué pour la
guerre en crimée et ses fins pour
replacer les choses méprisant et
craignent ainsi que les chrétiens
évidemment c'est les ukrainiens c'est
aussi les populations russe qui
voudraient qu'ils avaient pas la guerre
qui est qu'ils sont très mal à l'aise et
qui sont aussi réprimés par rapport à ça
remettons déjà les choses à leur place
alors si on revient sur les conséquences
évidemment sur l'agriculture en france
le premier ministre est en train de
bâtir un plan de résilience qui va
comporter aussi des des chaussures pour
la peau les agriculteurs qu'est ce que
vous vous préconisez qu'est-ce que quels
sont vos demandes les demandes déjà
c'est d'arriver à différencier ce qui va
falloir faire de court terme et de moyen
et long terme j'allais dire on doit se
saisir de cet événement dramatique
qu'est la guerre en ukraine comme a été
elle est encore le coc vider la pandémie
pour s'interroger sur notre souveraineté
alimentaire notre autonomie et notre
indépendance alimentaire et agricole au
niveau européen et de se dire qu'à
partir de là
vouloir toujours produire plus sachant
que pour produire plus faudrait des
engrais azotés et que là on va se
retrouver avec une flambée du prix du
gaz est donc soit on va encore en des
engrais viennent d'ukraine un
renchérissement de nos coûts de
production est ce qu on veut aller là
dedans ou est ce que au contraire on
veut avoir une agriculture qui donne les
moyens d'être plus autonome plus
résiliente pas moi je prends donc ça
veut dire accélérer la transition
écologique exactement c'est de se saisir
de sa pour pour l'accélérer et de se
dire ça doit être un point un point un
peu pivot où on se dit voilà on n'a plus
le choix fama emmanuel macron l'aï dit
c'est une folie de délégués notre
alimentation ben si c'est une folie on
va vers ses concitoyens de l'aide
alimentaire prend du temps c'est pas du
temps que je vais apprendre sans pour
autant faire une transition et met en
grève vous n'allez pas les trouver tout
de suite tu la benauge bien sûr que non
bien sûr que non mais mais ça veut dire
plutôt que que
de se dire à long terme on va aller
chercher du maïs aux états unis on va
aller
soi-disant de manière très solidaire
produire plus chez nous pour aller
alimenter les pays les pays du nord
africains ça ça peut être une solution
de court terme il faudra cette
solidarité il faudra arriver à avoir
tous ces échanges là pour ne permettre
qui est pas qu'on n'ajoute pas à la
guerre des crises une des crises
humanitaires mais ça doit pas être le
moyen de se dire ben il va falloir
demain encore produire plus et pour pour
aller on voit bien c'est l'enjeu pour
certains c'est d'aller gagner des parts
de marché le crédit s'arrête la russie
s'arrête aussi on va les progrès sur la
question c'est toujours est-ce qu'on
peut nourrir toute la population est ce
qu'on peut être autosuffisant mais j'ai
bien sûr bien sûr qu'on peut être
autosuffisant c'est à dire en faisant la
tradition la transition écologique en
ayant une certaine durabilité de
l'agriculture en se penchant sur sur des
moyens de produire autrement parce
qu'encore une fois on va se retrouver à
un moment charnière où à force de deux
mètres dans le sol de plus en plus
d'engrais azotés qui vont être de plus
en plus cher etc on va se retrouver à un
moment à avoir des difficultés à
produire plus difficultés qui seront
plus inacceptable pour une partie de la
population européenne et mondiale parce
qu'ils n'auront pas les moyens ce pays
cette alimentation donc si c'est
produire pour que ce ne soit accessible
qu'à une partie de la population quand
on aura les moyens enfin ça ça paraît
complètement complètement inconcevable
est incohérent les productivistes disent
que vous êtes à côté de la plaque comme
le dit brigitte ya plus en plus de
bouches à nourrir qu'il faudra forcément
produire plus et qu'avec vos idées un
peu archaïque entre guillemets c'est pas
moi qui le dis on va dans le mur
maintenant je pense pas qu'on va dans le
mur je pense que de fait on va dans le
mur avec une agriculture productiviste
qui est pas capable de se remettre en
cause quand on voit tout ce qu'elle
coûte à la société de manière générale
en impacts indirects en externalités
négatives à direct une agriculture
productiviste c'est la malbouffe
derrière s'est dit que ça peut être des
problèmes de santé cds pollution de
l'eau c'est des sols qui sont de moins
en moins en capacité d'être filtrants et
2 et 2 et 2
[Musique]
d'accepter les pluies diluviennes et
c'est donc tout ça ça doit nous nous
montrer que le modèle qu'on est en train
de
laisser à penser que c'est le seul en
capacité de nourrir l'humanité est en
fait en train de détruire nos capacités
de production sur le long terme dont
ceux pour nous c'est on doit se saisir
de cette de ce moment là pour réorienter
nos modèles de production installé plus
de paysannes et paysans également dans
léa qu'accompagner les pays
africains les pays qui sont dans des
dents et bd dans des mécanismes de
production qui doivent être encore
améliorée mais c'est de se dire qu'ils
ne doivent pas prendre modèle sur nous
et de se dire qu'ils vont aller aussi à
la destruction des paysans à avoir de
moins en moins de paysans qui travaille
alors de plus en plus de 2 de dépendance
de ces pays de ces paysans la aux
différentes firmes qui nous entoure
parce que aujourd'hui le modèle français
et européens ou américains pour nous et
pas du tout ce que vous dites moyen
terme et long terme mais on l'a vu dans
le reportage là la filière porcine elle
s'inquiète pour l'alimentation de ces
bêtes notamment et elle dit qu'elle est
peut-être mais menacé qu'est ce que vous
dites vous confédération paysanne à ces
éleveurs de porcs par exemple la
première chose qu'on dit c'est qu'on a
une certaine capacité de production sur
des éléments sur des terres aujourd'hui
qu'ils ne produisent pas de
de production pour l'alimentation
humaine et animale et quand je pense à
ça je pense pas aux jachères comme
l'expriment christiane lambert la fnsea
ou le ministre ce que les jachères c'est
enfin on nous on nous montrent un film
depuis quelques jours les jachères sont
très peu présentes sur le salon il faut
arrêter laurent clain il faut produire
il y en a déjà très peu de jachère c'est
à dire que il ya moins de il ya entre 1
et 2% de jachère au niveau français et
européen parce que il ya une nécessité
d'avoir sur les fermes des
infrastructures agro écologiques comme
on dit qui peuvent être des jachères
mais en fait la plupart des paysans ne
choisissent pas se les jachères pour
répondre aux infrastructures agro
écologiques il se sert de 2è qui sont
présentes sur la ferme de bosquets et se
servent de cultures intermédiaires entre
une culture d'hiver et une culture d'été
et met une culture intermédiaire qui
sert à ça donc ça sert un faux problème
nous la réalité c'est de se dire que
l'on doit déjà arrêté de mettre du blé
du maïs dans nos bagnoles dans les
méthaniseurs dans les agrocarburants et
de se dire que il y aura forcément un
débat à avoir sur notre taux sur notre
autonomie énergétique mais le premier
débat la première nécessité qu'on doit
avoir c'est un débat sur notre autonomie
alimentaire donc déjà et ça ça
représente à peu près 3% des surfaces en
france et en europe qui sont cultivées
pour faire des agrocarburants avec un
constat énergétique absolument mauvais
on venait d entrer dessus ça coûte du
gaz cinq ans de vie mais j'ai bon
carburant vous dis tout simplement
c'est en tout cas pendant ce temps là
c'est de dire exactement non mais c'est
de se dire que ces surfaces là ne
doivent plus être dédiés à la production
d'énergie mais elles doivent être dédiés
à la production alimentaire dire qu'on
ne peut pas accepter de laisser crever
des gens sur la planète ou de lait ou de
laisser des paysans dans dans la
possibilité d'unir leurs animaux pour
mettre du carburant la loi et il est
doublé
dans une chaudière pour se chauffer
l'hiver ou du maïs dans un méthanier
dire que vous demandez aussi des aides
financières pour mettre du carburant
dans votre tracteur ou face aux dépenses
énergétiques il va forcément avoir avoir
un rush un renchérissement de l'énergie
et il faut pas que ce soit encore une
une fracture énergétique
des bières vous faut laisser passer il
faudra forcément avoir un accompagnement
de l'état emmanuel macron l'a déjà dit
au salon de l'agriculture en disant qu'
on va aller dans dans des sanctions par
rapport à la russie pour essayer d'aller
vers
obtenir un arrêt cessez le feu et ces
sanctions ont des répercussions mais
l'état l'europe nous accompagnera et et
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas penser
autrement brigitte une toute petite
question avant qu'on passe à autre chose
là je vois que vous et on parle des
nouvelles technologies qui vous
effraient de cette guerre en ukraine qui
est sombre je disais le figaro magazine
il ya quinze jours qui disait au pays
des paysans heureux est ce que ça existe
les paysans heureux bien sûr que ça
existe les paysans heureux on se
revendique souvent à la confédération
paysanne elle d'essayer d'être des
paysans heureux ou pour ce qui arrive
d'être des paysans heureux moi je suis
un paysan heureux je me revendique e
lettres des deux bien dans mes baskets
bien dans mes bottes sur ma ferme je
fais le métier que je voulais faire j'ai
la chance d'être bien rémunérés pour ça
et de pouvoir travailler correctement
et de nombreux paysans sont par leur
choix soit individuelles soient
collectifs ont aussi cette capacité à
assumer leur choix être rémunérés pour
ça et et à produire une alimentation de
qualité puis à être remercié pour sa
part les voisins les consommateurs donc
il ya toute une partie qui ont du sens
et aussi toute une partie qui se
retrouvent dans le mur parce qu ils sont
pas rémunérés parce qu'ils sont cloués
au pilori dès qu'on parle d'un certain
modèle agricole moi ces gens là moi j'ai
envie de leur dire que c'est les
politiques agricoles qui ont été menées
depuis 30 ans qui les ont emmenés ici
c'est pas de leur fait ils sont victimes
de tout ça donc maintenant les
politiques agricoles doivent les sortir
du mur dans lesquelles ils l'ont dit et
moi j'ai envie de retrouver des paysans
heureux en france en europe et c'est
vous le porte parole de la confédération
paysanne qui allait oeuvrer pour ça
j'imagine allez on passe à présent au
dessert c'est le péché mignon
oui le péché mignon nicolas giraud c'est
une crème brûlée alors brigitte qui a
inventé ce dessert oui j'ai un peut
mener l enquête c'est sans doute les
catalans avec la crème catalane approche
de la crème brûlée mais un peu plus
lourd parce qu'ils aident à farine de
maïs la trace écrite de la première
recette daterait du 10ème siècle pour la
crème brûlée à la française il a fallu
attendre le 17e et à l'époque on se sert
de la pelle qui est au feu dont qui est
brûlante pour colorer le sucre et brûlé
la crème alors depuis quand vous voulez
mais cette crème brûlée nicolas giraud
c'est un souvenir d'enfance et c'est pas
nettement la crème brûlée de souvenirs
d'enfance le souvenir d'enfance c'est
davantage le flanc quart hélas le flou
les oeufs le lait et le caramel au tour
le flanc qui baigne dans le caramel et
chocolat on s'est trompé non mais c'est
aimer c c'est exact ensemble à la
ccc le souvenir de deux de cette
alliance du lait des
vraiment à l'enfance je n'ai pas
d'affirmer par elle même pas ouais bon
votre maman c'est votre dessert préféré
du coup j'ai un paquet de desserts
préférés mais oui mais oui
je suis plus sucré ouais alors goûté je
vous ai dit si ça vous plaît jus de
goûter ce très bon mais je m'écoutais
c'est le petit craquant la nouvelle en
fait comme est bon c'est leur fête des
crèmes brûlées chez vous moi oui notre
femme puisque m ma femme et mon fils
j'ai un j'ai mon fils ce moment deuxième
qui qui cuisine un petit peu quand même
bien essayé de se mettre à cuisiner qui
nous fait dédé c'est donc c'est un grand
salut mots comme ça va s'associer de
griller du mot qui va bien pour et c'est
cette différence de texture que vous
appréciez ouais
c'est bon c'est bon comment le tout
revient alors nicolas giraud vous savez
nous sommes en pleine campagne
présidentielle nous sommes donc
intéressés aux us et coutumes de
l'elysée au au repas nos dirigeants
politiques et pour cela vous nous avez
concocté jambières un quiz
présidentielle oui à kris présidentielle
en accord avec le salon de l'agriculture
emmanuel macron détient le record de la
plus longue visite du salon de
l'agriculture c'était en 2019 combien de
temps nicolas giraud at-il arpenté les
allées je parle denis d'emmanuel mâcon
bien entendu réponse à 4 heures réponse
dès 14h30 ces cinq heures trente dès 12h
et 14h30
la journée avait été longue
battre un record à battre heures après
on aimerait autant que que le record
soit pas sûrement seulement sur le temps
passé au salon mais sur les les actes de
ce colloque sont ok merci nicolas giraud
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci à
chez françoise qui nous a fourni ce très
bon dessert et à la boucherie pascal
bouttier avenue mozart pour ce très bon
boeuf bourguignon rendez vous bien sûr
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de politique à table sur lcp